欢迎你学习白泽国际站运营实战系统课
这一节课我们来讲一下关于老店铺的运营实战方法
这些方法适用于哪些店铺呢
比如说那些做得很优秀的店铺
闲置了几年的店铺
接手效果一般的老店铺
都可以用这个方法去操作
或者是说你之前做了A行业
现在换到了B行业
对于B行业产品都不太了解的情况下
也可以用这个方法去进行操作店铺 你的方法才具备可迁移的效果 因为很多时候我发现有些人操作A行业的效果挺好的 但是去操作B行业的话效果就很差
为什么会这样呢 因为他没有真正的掌握整体的一个思路跟框架 他只知道某些方法 因为这些方法会过时的 而且是在不同的店铺会失效的
但是呢 它的整体的思路和框架是通用的 那么你有思路跟框架之后 你再根据这个店铺以及行业的具体情况去衍生出你的方法
那么这样的方法才是更加适用的 才会更加容易拿得到结果
所以为什么很多人学了很久 但是一换个行业 或者是换个店铺换个产品 好像就没有思路 不知道怎么开展工作
我相信很多人都有遇到过这种情况嘛 所以这节课就是来帮你解决这个问题的 那么老店铺它具体按照什么样的方法来操作呢
第一个 我们一定要按照店铺定位来指导我们店铺操作去提升我们的巡盘总量和巡盘的质量
一切的操作都要围绕着我们这个店铺的目标去努力 特别是那些一年以上的店铺一定要重视这个思路
这个思路会指导着你去做各种有效的动作
那么具体什么操作呢
我们来看一下
第一个就是产品知识
也就是你刚换行业的时候一定要去学习这些产品知识
或者是说你新开拓一个品类的时候
一定要重点重点在产品知识的学习
以及你们公司有什么样的优势
或者是公司现在处于什么阶段
这个一定要去掌握这个
因为很多人 其实他不关注这个 也不关注这些 他就总是围绕着 好像自己操作的技能很强
再强的技能 如果不懂产品 不知道公司当前处于什么阶段 有什么优势 以及公司的资源有什么你都不清楚
那么你怎么能够很好的去了解你的目标买家呢 怎么能够充分的把公司的资源用上呢
所以在我们操作店铺前 我们一定要把这个板块了解得非常的透彻 可以根据公司之前的本档内容以及培训的内容去学习就可以了
第二个也是很重要的 关于店铺定位 刚才我们前面讲的新店铺的定位 跟这个老店铺一样
你一定要去把这些弄清楚 塞到产品线 国家人群 产品支持 这些全部弄清楚
第三步 因为你接手的是优秀的店铺 或者是闲置的店铺 或者是说一些效果一般的店铺 所以你接手之后 你一定要先对它进行一个整体的诊断
就是店铺综合数据评估 你要知道你们店铺当前处在什么阶段 行业均值还是行业优秀
那么各个板块的数据情况又是如何的 你一定要提前的去掌握好这些综合数据
第二个就是流量 转化 订单等等这些方面的问题 哪个维度缺失最严重 或者是说效果最差的
那么你把这些了解清楚了 你是不是就能够制定一个更合理的运营计划
是不是就知道我要重点从哪个维度进行去突破 就不至于你每天就在瞎忙了
第三个就是店铺标签跟寻盘质量这些 你有没有进行一个判断
比如说你们店铺定位已经确定了 美国等等这些国家是核心的国家
但是呢 你们店铺来的巡盘都是那些非洲 非洲 东南亚的
是不是说明你们的店铺标签混乱且不精准 巡盘质量差
巡盘质量差就是导致订单转化非常的低
所以这些你要去了解 如果是巡盘质量差
那么你就要去构想一下如何去解决这个问题
因为我们前面也讲过了相关的一些具体方法 你就要去把你具体要操作的方法 内容列出来 形成你的运营计划
这样是不是你的店铺运营的方向就非常清晰 同时你的计划也明了了 是不是就知道每周每月你要做什么事情
是不是这个店铺就有一个更好的正向积累的数据了 所以这个板块一定要非常的重视
如果对这个诊断不是很清楚 那么我们就参考之前我们学的诊断的内容 以及诊断的方法去应用就可以了
第四个就是你要去盘点一下 现在这个店铺到底有什么样的资源来帮助你去达成你的目标
因为很多时候如果你连资源有什么都不知道 那么你前面所定的目标怎么能够确保它能够达成呢
所以一定要去盘点一下 比如说你们店铺里面的产品总量是多少 关键词覆盖完了没有
油品 爆品 真爆品 到底有多少 这些维度在哪个层级 跟行业的相比 跟同行相比 第三就是你们有没有问点 有没有顶点 橱窗多少个预算
直通车多少每天
那现在这个店铺 直通车的计划类型是什么 他在推广什么类产品 选盘转化怎么样 选盘的成本怎么样
这些店铺的一些数据
而店铺的一些资源 你都要去盘点清楚 做到心里有数 只有做到心里有数的时候 我们才知道 我缺什么资源去达成这个目标
那么我缺的这些资源 公司能不能给到我 或者是说 我能通过什么的方式去获取这些资源 或者是我能不能换种方式去操作这个店铺来达成我的目标
这些是不是非常的有效 如果是你把这些盘点出来
那么第五个就是你要去把整个店铺进行一个规划跟计划
我们是按照以数据为基础以及和老板业务沟通后
在制定我们的运营规划和计划开始执行
这里有一个非常容易犯的错误
我们不和老板也不和业务沟通
我们自己去操作一个店铺
操作的时候 后期数据很好 或者是很多了之后
你会发现 这些寻盘 那些产品都不是公司想要的
这样是不是会导致你浪费了非常多的时间和精力
都花在以前去做那些非目标国家的寻盘和非目标的品类
这是不是瞎忙了 是吧 所以说为什么前期一定要定位好
还要跟老板业务沟通好呢
就是为了让你的工作有非常明确的方向跟计划
做的事情都是围绕着目标去做的 这样做才会有更多的正向积累
第二个就是你要有具体的目标 有截止的时间 有具体执行的内容
也就是你这个规划跟计划里面一定要有截止时间和具体执行的内容
有时间你就知道我在什么时间段内要完成这件事情
有内容就能够知道我每天要做什么 每周要做什么 每个月要做什么
不然的话 事情一多 或者是说忙起来的时候 重点的内容 能够促进店铺持续增长的关键行动都被忽视了
所以这个计划要做的时候 把这些标明是非常重要的
那么第六个步骤就是推广跟信保 其实跟我们新店铺的运营的方法是一样的
最终还是要推广跟信保 比如说第一个就是你开始去新建计划了 是吧
那么你是不是要去推广 加信保 他后面还有很多流程嘛 那么你达到了这一步 后面的你就接着继续按照你的思路去做就可以了 订单绑定
这些要和业务沟通好 绑哪些产品 具体怎么绑 预算申请 向老板申请 那么你要怎么样去申请这些预算
你不可能就直接说老板我需要300块钱增长到500块钱 那你要给他增长的理由吧
那么你给300块钱涨到500块钱 那你要达成什么效果 你要写出来 或者是说 你要把增长的一个大致的数据 能够给它呈现一下 不然的话 那为什么你要求300涨到500就直接给你涨这些预算 是吧
所以我们做事情都是要有依据 而且是能够还得到结果 或者是通过这些预算的增长 我能够达到一个预期的效果
这样才能够更容易的去申请预算 那么这个就是关于老店铺运营的一些方法跟思路
如果你正在接手一个老店铺的时候就可以直接先把这个板块先学了 然后再去操作 这样的效果会更好一点
那么这节课我们就先讲到这里 下节课我们再见